so that's why it went viral
yesterday SNL had a
skit about covid and we'll play a little
bit of this but uh I don't know
maybe a little bit late but let's watch
are you feeling tired and worn down Sick
of the Endless grind at work
exhausted by your family desperate for
some peace and quiet
then ask your doctor about covid by
simply getting covered you're guaranteed
a five and sometimes even 10-day
vacation from all of life's problems I
needed a break just some time away from
everyone so my doctor suggested I get
covid and it was the greatest week of my
life all I wanted was to sit on the good
part of the couch and watch the Netflix
I want to watch and I was finally able
to thanks to covid at first I was
worried about getting coveted but my
doctor assured me it's fine now I'm
triple vaxxed quadruple if you count HPV
so it's my time to shop side effects of
covid include having covet which is
still kind of bad but doesn't it seem
different now I definitely got sick
but I also got paid for 10 days to never
leave a blanket plus I got a great story
I could tell people at work it was like
I had a bad cold for three days
of course I had to isolate from my three
kids because I didn't want to get them
sick but uh what do they eat
15 days to be extra safe
so there's that you know I love spending
the holidays with my family and one of
the ways that I like to do that is with
delicious meat from good ranchers as a
special gift to my listeners this
holiday season good ranchers is giving
away two Black Angus New York strip
steaks free with your order there are
two uh 12 ounce Steakhouse quality cuts
a 70 value for free black angus tastes
better and is more tender than any other
beef black angus meat is marbled in such
a way that the fat is distributed thinly
and evenly this marbling gives you a
consistent flavor that you don't get
with other meats plus the Black Angus
from good ranchers is hand cut and
trimmed by expert butchers so you know
every piece is going to be Exquisite
while grocery store meat prices are on
the rise good ranchers is dedicated to
helping you save as much as possible if
you subscribe to good ranchers today you
can lock in your price and avoid those
insanely high prices at the grocery
store and get some free meat while
you're at it so it's the best of all
possible worlds go to goodrancers.com
Walsh use code walls to check out for
this special offer that's
goodrancers.com Walsh for 2 two Black
Angus New York strip steaks free with
your order
you know it's every time I see something
like this it just uh it just frustrates
me because that would have been
that's that skit right there two years
ago
that would have been edgy
and uh and offensive to a lot of people
and hilarious
largely for that reason
but now
it's like they're coming they're coming
around to these jokes and these
observations and everything that most of
us noticed two years ago and we're
supposed to give them credit
and there are far too many people who
are willing to give them that credit
being way too generous I think
uh no it's too too late I mean what was
SNL doing two years ago
like they didn't have a live audience
they didn't I think they should in fact
they shut down completely
I wasn't paying much attention that I I
admit but uh they weren't making jokes
like that I could tell you that
wait until it's completely safe that I
mean that that's comedy these days right
that's what comedy has become wait until
it's it wait until the coast is clear
it's completely safe
you won't offend a single soul and then
make the joke
doesn't work quite the same that'll do
it for this portion of the shows and
move over to the members block hope to
see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]